[Music]
the billboards for girls are all over
Los Angeles they're all over New York is
is that that's a very strange situation
for you I would imagine it's really
interesting I mean I've been getting a
lot of texts from my friends in text
images my friends in Los Angeles all the
text they sent me have like beautiful
nan de faced billboards because I think
in LA they're higher ups their high up
so no one can get to reach them but in
New York people can reach them and I
have to say I've been very impressed by
the wit of some of the de facers I
actually I brought a picture to show you
brought this is a picture our friend of
yours took I think of let's take a look
and let's see what's what are they right
on your forehead can we see oh yeah horn
number three that's nice I was kind of
offended because why am i whole number
three I'm the only one who shows my
breasts on the show I'm the only one who
shows my butt on the show I'm gonna put
myself on the line and I'm horn number
three like why could I not have been
horn number one that's the big complaint
if you work hard someday you'll be
number one I believe in you